you
[Music]
okay hi everyone I'm bear jerky I'm at
our studio on the shiny team and I help
out with shiny development not
necessarily directly with shiny except
for in this case but help around the
shiny ecosystem a lot as well
github in twitter h Lurky there's only
one of me promise I set up my parents up
so they don't have the same names
alright so let's get started so a
situation we're all here because of
shiny
so we built a shiny application that's
awesome
we had a new reactive feature to the
application because that's why we use
shiny also awesome but very common
behavior is that that reactive output
possibly does not update and so we're a
little sad and also confused so let's
check the console because there's always
information in the console right that's
far that's where all the trace back
information is no errors now we need to
start panicking because we're in trouble
I hope by the end of this talk that that
will not be a scary situation to be in
so we're going to talk about debugging
that reactive code that caused that
issue debugging reactive code as that
example just showed is not easy it's not
a trivial task because you have working
code no errors are being produced how
can we explore what's going on because
it's happening later you have to know a
lot of information for this reactive
code you have to know that R value
that's fair you also have to know who
depends on who such as in the modules
can get messy very quickly and you must
do this over time that is not easy it's
a lot of things to keep track of
normally with arch just linear solution
react log if you're familiar with the
react log before
congratulations you can be really
excited I'm not going to introduce the
old the old set up so what is react log
your clog is a snapshot
or his like log of all the reactive
interactions within a shiny application
so just so that we're all on the same
page let's review this for just a quick
second so reactive programming it's a
paradigm concerned with propagation of
change no need to remember a lot of
things there's three types that we
always talk about we have our sources
such as input key a we have conductors
such as a reactive where I create a new
value given that input key a and then I
have some end points such as output key
B which is one of my many render
functions in this case render print or
we could have an observe where the
propagation ends there at the observe
statement if we were to kind of look at
a dependency tree of this it would look
similar to this where we have an input
such as key a going into value which was
then used in output key B or even in a
the observed statement and we'll get
into a more in-depth look at that later
so react log we're gonna get set up this
dependency tree and then we're going to
Traverse backwards and forwards through
this reactivity history we're also going
to be able to search for reactive
elements because even though we all love
our hello world applications we're
building some complex complex
applications and need to search for that
once we've searched for them we want to
filter so we can filter down and make
our large complex app a very small
interactive tiny dependency tree and
then that way we can explore efficiently
as to where our errors are coming from
and then before I show the demo on this
it's built on cytoscape j/s which is a
really nice JavaScript graph library
because that's what we're doing here so
set up to install currently it's on
github oh so we'll do dev tools and
install github our studio react log but
it will be a natural natural dependency
of shiny
in 1.3 so just wait a few months when
that comes out on cran and usage set an
option for shiny react log is true and
then from then on it's just normal work
so we'll run our shiny app it'll start
recording all of that history and then
finally we'll say you know command F 3
which is the legacy react log key
combination or ctrl F 3 if your Windows
and just to kind of make sure that we're
recording everything these are just a
quick overview of everything that we are
recording in in react log if you see
some things that look familiar great if
you see some new things awesome I hope
you add them into your app at some point
but we are doing this just at surface
level with many more to come
ok so for fun stuff let's start
debugging some shiny applications for 3
o'clock so Pythagoras I'm gonna do a
demo application with Pythagoras theorem
because if I were to explain that I'm
going to calculate see we already know
how this app should work we have our
input a we have an input B we calculate
sum a squared B squared maybe a C
squared and then C and then now we have
our answer that to be displayed with a
render method so you can already kind of
build this horizontal graph in our minds
as to what this should look like so
let's take a quick look at the app so we
have my server function here where I
have input a goes to a squared B to B
squared and reactive
a squared plus B squared is C squared
and C we're good then I have some two
outputs output C text and C verbatim
should be good so let's run this app I
have my options set up at the top of the
script and let's change to the other
well-known triangle where B is 5 and see
updates value great and then let's
change this to a is 12 so now we have C
is 13 great let's check out the react
log for this
so command FN or f3 and this is what we
get looks great up there so this will
default load to where the first time
that shiny is idle it's waiting for the
user to do some interactions so we have
our a value our B value calculates a
squared B squared to go into C or C
squared to C and then we have our two
outputs as we step through the first
thing that I did was I invalidated B I
set it to the value 5
so as B gets changed you know can see
the input value is changed here and then
invalidation will propagate all the way
down so now all the B squared C squared
C and everything has been invalidated so
we'll back out of our invalidation
process and then now we can start our
calculation process this is where the
reactivity code is being triggered so
the C text is being wanting to calculate
it needs C right and so now we're
starting to go back up our tree I
already have a squared so we can just
pull that value or again calculate and
down we go
same with C verbatim but since we
already have C calculated no need to
duplicate that and that is your typical
shiny interaction it's working how we
want just to skip through quickly we did
this for a as well and you can see the
same interaction that you'd expect there
so broken Pythagoras now let's switch
this this model up because we know what
to expect in our model and let's switch
to that one in this case I was a little
sloppy when I was creating my
application it looks good on the surface
but you know I may have some bug's
coming into my code so let's do a quick
refresh so here let's do the same
interaction I change it to five well see
print didn't change but see did so
that's odd
and then let's change our a value to 12
and see changed again but see print
didn't so now we have some odd behavior
let's let's explore what's going on with
that so this is not the same graph that
we saw a prior there's some ghost edges
some missing edges there and also we
have no connectivity to see verbatim so
we can double check that as well so as I
step through saying that I updated be
nothing happened actually a was the next
reactive element because be in the app
is not connected in this example input a
is calculating B squared and so that is
now a bug that I have found if I wanted
to I could change it quickly here and go
back to B and then stop the app
and if I change now B to 5c should
update maybe I didn't save but I would
do the same thing in there oh I didn't
use B squared that's that was the deal
sorry I have more bugs in the in the
code I found more so actually what
happened be changed right and that's
that's what I did there but there was an
isolate call a rogue isolate call so it
did not propagate through and that is
one of the trip ups since I just
experienced swell that you can have with
reactivity so we could remove that
isolate call and it would be fixed
there's many more things that we can do
but for presentation time I'm going to
continue on just make sure I covered all
of them yeah there's that rogue
isolation call so let's show off some
searching within react log Joe yes they
demoed his cran Wales application and
it's a very you know standard
application but it's also a very dense
application there's a lot of reactivity
going on underneath the hood so if we
want to run this we just need to set our
flag again and then we can say run
github his cran Wales application on the
synchronous branch we'll just make it
easy for us so if we go to that one
escape and source so we'll download the
repo open up the application and click
through as joyed click through it's
downloading the data parsing the data
right now
displaying perfect so we have our cran
wheels let's open up the other tab whale
is by our and let's I'm marking a time
point right now we got the notification
good let's change the top-end
downloaders and then we have a detail
view so I'm just stepping through as Jo
did in much faster pace so let's double
check that reactivity this is a very
dense application it's not that a big
application either but it gets dense
very quickly one of the views that we
remit like I remember seeing was the
detailed view here where we have three
bits of information so I can look at
that reactivity that is actually
[Music]
stepping through that detail view is
this guy right here is the important
part because he has three bits of
numbers and also a plot that is produced
so what we can do even though this is
quite small if I double-click I'll then
filter down to just that parent tree so
I get all the descendants and all the
ancestors of that particular node if I
wanted to do it a different way I can
search for detail and I have some extra
arguments detail download and now I'm
back to that one app so that makes it
very quick even if you have two thousand
actives you're not going to be
overloaded I've experienced one app that
has over 2,000 reactive elements on
start and it's open source so it's great
to test against works great so we run
our app very dense so some things to
remember for the reactive coding shiny
outputs that are not visible are not
calculated this is on purpose this is a
direct design decision by SHINee so you
may see some output elements that just
hang out and validate it forever they're
not on display
so you may need to open that second tab
or do something else with that if new
reactive elements are created for every
user interaction such as a click or an
input value change
you've probably coded what's referred to
as an anti solution Joe talks about this
and it's shiny Devcon presentation and
what it will do with react log is it
will cause the react log to explode
it'll get very big because the more
reactives will be done for every user
interaction so if this happens it's okay
your shiny app isn't exploding on memory
I promise there is garbage collection
going on but the graph will be quite big
right now and then react log is not a
performance debugger
it's a reactivity debugger if you want
performance debugging or inspection
please use profetas is very good at that
and it'll tell you very quickly where to
do that and change your code and then
last word of caution do not keep react
log enabled when deploying to production
your memory will be very mad at you when
we're all done so future ideas I want to
visually differentiate user sessions
right now everything is all displayed as
one graph you may have independent
graphs show up which is just fine but
it's nice to maybe silo off a user's so
that it's very visual as to what's
happening at one time we also want to
display the values of also of the
outputs and reactive values currently we
only have it for the input values but
that's how a standard react log is
working so that'll come up in the next
version of react log we also want to do
expandable and collapsible groups this
is one of my favorite ideas about this
project
things such as render print or render
sorry render plot render plot actually
inserts like four or five different
reactive values for every render plot
function it's not something that you did
it's something that the render plot
function
so we should be able to collapse that
down just say uh bundle it up to render
plot I don't care how it works just
gloss over that for me this would also
help for things like modules if you know
your module is solid you could collapse
it down to a single group and then we'd
be good to go also we I'd like to remove
objects from the react log graph so if
you happen to have coded an anti
solution that's fine but if the other
elements have been garbage collected we
should remove them so that they don't
present a possible state that is kind of
confusing it's not there on your machine
so I don't think we should have to worry
about it anymore and then finally I'd
like to create a super app of react log
and prof is that we'll both analyze the
performance or time aspect as well as
the reactivity and the state of your
shiny application in one tool similar to
prof is as if we step through on react
log it would highlight the code in your
reactivity to where it's being done
that's a super app in a dream so we'll
see slides or the github repo is done at
our studio slash react log
don't forget to enable it before you run
your shiny application for just tips on
shiny reactivity there's the link to the
our studio articles and slides can be
found on bitly there and then apparently
everything is good with you guys but do
you have any questions thank you
[Applause]
do you have record capability or
versioning because this would be really
fantastic when you put out an app and
you know the reactivities right to have
it versioned as well as the the step
through basically recorded and then when
somebody makes a change and break
something you can see the difference yes
so I don't have a comparison tool setup
for that but the way that we've made the
page to show up is that it is just a
single web page that's savable you can
just download that as is and then you
can compare the two chrome pages after
you even shut down your computer and
you'll be just fine there that way we
can keep like a working pythagoras up
right in the middle
does it have her could you add source
code annotations like which file which
line something was defined it it's
currently being exported from shiny it's
a feature that we do want to do so it is
in the workings things like render you I
insert UI and stuff that changes HTML
how how can is there plan to to be able
to log that as mean that they're
changing the HTML or like there's render
UI in the script and I'm creating a new
object and then and the user is creating
a new and new object
is there a way to track that HTML was
changing I would have to defer that you
would understand the method being run I
can tell you that when it's being
changed because the output value will be
set with render UI you have your output
dollar my area will be updated so I can
tell you when it's being when it's being
set that's where I would like to have
that grouped module set up where I can
say this is running through the render
UI method right now but currently it'll
just show some temporary variables that
are used
[Music]